[Musique]
on est où ici on est au bar jauge
qu'est-ce que cet argent
l'ancienne résidence privée ancienne
résidente privé de stephen jones
on veut garder l'honneur de cette maison
et en faisant de une bouffe qui est prêt
comportant qui est qui répondait l'image
anglais c'est quand même un baron
[Rires]
classe en septembre dernier dans le
cadre du festival you eat l'ancienne
maison de cet aristocrate qui était à la
tête de la banque de montréal et du
canadien pacifique a été choisi pour
donner un atelier sur la confection du
boeuf wellington saignant ce plat qui
doit son nom à arthur weasley premier
duc de wellington
le célèbre britannique avec une à paléo
lors de la bataille de waterloo en 1815
vous voyez la coloration combat là elle
est parfaite idée par deux chefs les
douze gastronomes ont ainsi pu préparer
ce plat en évitant les pièges la
difficulté c'est la cuisson de la viande
bien sûr qui est râpé dans une faillite
âge qu'on peut pas voir la couleur et de
le rendre bien coup ce fut au tour donc
vous gardez vraiment le croustillant du
ve étage donc ça c'est la difficulté
le cas denis pièce d'accord la duxelle
le chef du bar georges nous aident à
contourner ces difficultés pour débuter
il prépare une duxelle qui est constitué
de champignons de paris
finement haché sauter au bar avec des
oignons et des échalotes
là je dirai jamais peu à peu près 500 g
de champignons la crème aussi c'est une
touche de crème c'est pas beaucoup de
crème le beurre noisette de beurre
remettre l'échalote du teint un peu de
vin blanc
ça va réduire ce chiffre est bon la
duxelle carrie son rôle dans le boeuf
wellington la duxelle c'est celui qui
ramène le côté filles le côté boisé et
heureux donc c'est ce qui est très
important qui est que le succès soit
très très sec
il faut que ce soit sec alors là on a
notre filet mignon on va la saisine et
sel soit généreux poivre tout cas on va
la faire saisir c'est vraiment ça
convient autant le processus consiste à
saisir la viande pour lui donner une
belle couleur et un bon goût après ça on
va la faire reposer on va leur emballé
avec le tas duxelles le l'épinard est le
prosciutto et finalement la pâte
feuilletée
c'est pourquoi on l'a fait refroidir on
l'appellerait produire pour pouvoir
mieux le manipuler
donc on veut pas travailler qu on
s'échauffe tout ça ça tient pas bien
maintenant on va prendre notre boeuf qui
est là on va l'abattre jeunes et avec un
peu disons le chef ajoute une mince
couche d'épinards cuits lors de
l'enrobage ce qu'il faut faire c'est
très important
c'est on va le prendre on va leur
tournée pour l'atelier les participants
n'ont pas intégré cet ingrédient
optionnel pour la confection de leurs
portions individuelles c'est pas un truc
qui va dire qu'on part armand à eau du
csel ça c'est pas le choix pas le choix
du csel ouifinance exactement après
avoir enveloppé le filet mignon de la
mince couche d'épinards il étendra la
duxelle sur le lit de prosciutto
maintenant on va la retrouver
on les sert bien quand même on veut
vraiment le bien le maître pour conques
ont fait le bowling thonon le couple
qu'ils soient bien tight puis on vient
rouler le tout dans son enveloppe final
je le roule mais tout encore une fois en
gardant bien serré et là on va déjeuner
avec un peu de sourire dof
on a marqué un peu après ça on va mettre
un peu de fleur de sel ou l'assaisonner
un peu loupé
alors le pas mais oublie afin que la
croûte soient bien dorés la cuisson se
fera 400 de grille pour environ 12
minutes et on va les faire reposer donc
qui est fait en sorte que la chaleur va
continuer à rentrer dedans on va faire
poser un minimum de huit minutes et on
va la coupe et on va le servir
[Musique]
[Rires]
c'est très bon c'est un beau mariage ça
très beau mariage dans le filet mignon
on a les épinards on à l'adduction de
champignons le prosciutto qui me
reviennent au score qui nous donne un
petit côté salé et comme c'est à
l'assiette comme je trouve durant le
temps des fêtes c'est bien c'est festif
c'est à partager ses familiales
c'est agréable de le mettre dans le sens
de la table vous souhaite un bon temps
des fêtes
et merci à vous aussi
[Musique]